[Music]
stand-up paddling has become a popular
sport but paddle boards have been around
for over 3,000 years
contemporary boards rely on modern
materials to make light and reliable
paddle boards suited for leisure as well
as for competition this paddle board is
made with vinyl ester resin and
laminated fiberglass it's equipped with
an onboard lighting system an anchor and
a neoprene rubber non-slip pad in the
gel coating room
a technician wipes a release agent on
the paddle board mold to make the
surface smooth and clean another
technician positions the fin channel on
the mold using a thin fiberglass
template as a guide he uses an airless
pumping system to spray the mold with a
vinyl ester gel coating mixed with
hardener
[Music]
he takes a mil gage to make sure the
hull thickness is even a technician
prepares to make the first structural
layer of the hull using a three-quarter
ounce bi-directional fiberglass mat
first he pulls out a panel of fiberglass
and covers the gel coated surface using
fabric scissors he cuts the mat and
makes the fiberglass skin as tight as
possible he tears them that to conform
it to the rounded shape of the gel coat
and fits the mat to the edge of the hull
he applies vinyl ester resin with a
paint roller the resin saturates the
fiberglass which merges with the gel
coating extra material is placed over
the fin channel to strengthen the
structural bond between the channel and
the hull
then the technician uses a bubble roller
to push out air bubbles he applies a
second coat of fiberglass to reinforce
the structural integrity of the board in
the assembly room another technician
fits a template on the board deck and
traces the contours of the hand grab
mount with a pencil he uses an air saw
to cut out a slot in the fiberglass
laminate to fit the hand grab now
[Music]
he binds the hand grab mount to the hall
with a coat of vinyl ester resin within
about 20 minutes
the laminate hardens next plastic tubing
for the internal anchoring system is
installed a technician applies a bonding
adhesive to the to securing it in place
he attaches the tube with tie wraps so
it doesn't get tangled inside the hall
he installs a jam cleat for the rope
that will allow the paddler to manually
control the anchor from the deck
[Music]
the hulls cured vinyl ester resin is now
firmly bonded to the structural laminate
the assembler applies expanding adhesive
and positions and expanded polypropylene
foam stringer inside the hall the foam
stringers are the backbone of the board
they support the weight of the paddler
on the deck while keeping the board as
light as possible using a nylon wedge
and a rubber mallet the assembler
removes the mold from the hall
since the hall is so lightweight two
assemblers can lift and flip it onto a
cart an assembler trims off the excess
laminate using an air cutter fitted with
a diamond cutting blade he levels the
foam stringers with a file blade
ensuring the tightest possible fit
between the hall and death he applies
expanding foam adhesive on the stringers
before he places the deck on the foam
with the help of a co-worker the
adhesive quickly binds the parts
together the vinyl rubber ale designed
as a side protection masked the joint
between the deck and the hall
the hull contains a dry storage hatch
where the onboard battery is housed the
8 amp hour battery can activate the
power pole a micro anchor designed for
shallow waters in deeper waters a
paddler can manually activate the
internal anchor system with the 16 foot
nylon cord finally this board is ready
to hit the water